chargez un peu moins pour séduire plus
d'abonnés et encaisser des revenus
publicitaires c'est le pari que fait
Netflix à compter du premier novembre de
même que Disney plus à partir du début
décembre aujourd'hui les gens ont des
budget beaucoup plus serrés au niveau du
divertissement et j'avoue que l'offre
publicitaire qui va coûter moins cher
que l'offre sans publicité va
probablement avoir plus de succès avec
les temps économiques qu'on connaît le
présentement
le nouvel abonnement de Netflix coûtera
6 dollars par mois 4 dollars de moins
que le forfait de base et 10 dollars de
moins que le forfait standard en échange
les clients verront 4 à 5 minutes de
publicité à l'heure parce que les gens
vont être prêts je pense que oui parce
que c'est pas comme si ça tombe nulle
part on connaît ça la publicité entre
pendant les émissions et avant et après
alors c'est une adaptation à faire si on
désire payer moins cher mais reste que
dans les deux cas autant chez Disney que
chez Netflix si vous êtes prêts à payer
plein prix vous en aurez pas de
publicité pour le moment selon
l'Observatoire des technologies médias
62% des Québécois francophones
souscrivent actuellement à Netflix suivi
Amazon Prime vidéo et Disney plus puis
l'extrait de tout point TV et crève avec
13% chacun et le club illico de
Vidéotron avec 11% des ménages québécois
abonnés
a vu son nombre chuté pour la première
fois au début de l'année avant de
rebondir cet été il cherche donc de
nouvelles sources de revenus à court
terme naturellement en décembre
l'industrie va pas imploser mais c'est
vu comme toutes les nouveautés comme ça
qui arrive sur le plan des modèles
d'affaires au début on craint pas trop
on s'aperçoit finalement que c'est
encore un nouveau joueur qui vient
chercher dans une tarte qui est déjà
fortement fragilisée je pense que dans
l'univers des plateformes tout point TV
se place bien surtout avec ces nouveaux
modèles là qui arrivent je pense qu'on
est un petit peu peut-être précurseur
parce qu'on avait déjà le format avec
publicité on va voir arriver je pense
que on sait pas comment l'univers des
plateformes ne cesse de changer il faut
rester au courant puis regarder
qu'est-ce qui se passe autant Netflix
que Disney offre aux publicitaires un
accès à des dizaines de pays en même
temps et ils peuvent cibler très
précisément leur auditoire et je pense
qu'à long terme il y a un vrai défi pour
l'industrie et j'ai pas encore vu de
piste pour apprendre quel serait le
modèle d'affaires d'une industrie
québécoise de la télé dans 10 ans ou
dans 20 ans avec tous ces nouveaux
joueurs là qui sont ajoutés
ici marie-claumorin Radio-Canada
Montréal
[Musique]